I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details, and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Hello. Hi there. of VFF Stories or the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Hi there. We are excited. Yeah, if you read the episode description for today's episode, you're in the right place. Yes. So here's the thing, we have a very special guest today. Yeah, it is skateboarding legend, Tony Hawk.
I mean, I don't think you can even mention skateboarding without immediately thinking of Tony Hawk. He's the most famous skateboarder, of course. Yes. Yeah. I mean, he started skating professionally when he was just 14. He is a pioneer of the sport. He helped popularize and evolve the sport of skateboarding for like over 40 years.
And he's still skateboarding today. Yes. Yeah, he is also a successful entrepreneur in the skateboarding industry. He created Birdhouse Skateboards, Hawk Clothing, and his hugely successful video game, Tony Hawk's Pro Skater. And he is the founder of the non-profit Skate Park Project. That is his philanthropic mission
to help underserved communities create safe and inclusive public skate parks for all youth. Which I love it. I mean, I talked to Tony about it because I spent a lot of my high school years at skate parks because my first boyfriend was a skateboarder. How about that, you guys? Did you know Jenna would hang out at skate parks?
I found that out when we started talking about having Tony Hawk on. Yeah. I did not know that about you. It's so weird. And getting to talk to him and all of it, it brought up so many memories from my youth. After we did the interview with him, I took a picture with him,
and I just sent it to my friend. Wait, can I tell everyone what you said? You said, Tony, can I take a picture with you for I just sent it to my... Wait, can I tell everyone what you said? You said, Tony, can I take a picture with you for my boyfriend from high school? Yeah, I just want to send it to him with no explanation. So I actually don't have his contact information, but I sent it to the three girls from high school. I'm going to shout them out, Kim, Sarah, and Ellen.
The four of us would hang out at the skate park with our skateboarding boyfriends. And so I sent it to them. What did they say? And my friend Ellen wrote back, this is like a photo of my high school years in a nutshell. And my friend Sarah said, what is happening? Exactly. You all might be thinking what is happening? So we should probably share how this interview came about. When you think Tony Hawk, you probably don't think Office Ladies. About a year ago, we got word that Tony Hawk wanted to be a guest on Office Ladies
and we were like, what, what, what? We couldn't believe it. He's an icon. He's one of the greats. Tony Hawk. It turns He's one of the greats. He's Tony Hawk. He's Tony Hawk. It turns out he's a huge Office fan. We couldn't even believe that Office Ladies was on his radar. Yeah. But here was the thing, you know, we were in that last stretch of the Office rewatch. We were building up to the finale. I was finishing up chemotherapy.
So it took us a few months of trying to schedule Tony. We've been going back and forth and back and forth. And finally, it has all come together and he joined us in studio in person. In person, all six foot three of him was in our studio. He's so tall. I wasn't prepared for how tall. I had heard he's tall, but you know, I'm so short. So when he walked in, I was like,
oh my God, you're Tony Hawk. Oh my God, you're so tall. So yeah, I mean, it was such a delight to have him in the studio. We talk about the office. We talk about his career as a skateboarder, all the things he's learned along the way. He's such an interesting person
and he's had to pivot so many times in his life and Jenna and I could really relate to that. Yeah, I found it very inspirational. And you should all know that the newest version of his video game, Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 3 & 4 is out July 11th. Of this year? Yes, you can pre-order it now on Xbox Series XS,
Xbox One, PlayStation 4 & 5, Steam, Battle.net, Microsoft PC Store, and Nintendo Switch. Lady, my friend Buffy, who's a skateboarder, said a bunch of her friends are skaters that are featured in the game. And they had so much fun being a part of it and that it's gonna be really, really awesome. I mean, it looks so cool. I watched a little video of a behind the scenes
of making it. And, you know, they put Tony in one of those suits with the little, I don't know, what are they? They're like little camera balls like all over them. Yeah, like how they do Avatar. Yeah. Where they put the little balls on people. I wanna do that just once.
Oh, you wanna be a ball person? I wanna have the little camera balls, but I don't know what my expertise would be. Cause it's always something sort of fantastical or sports or. Yeah. I know. Well, we need to get you in like a fantasy movie, just right. Please, Lord, from her mouth to your ears.
Camera balls on Angela. Camera balls on me, please. In a fantasy film, please. Putting it out there. Putting it out there. Well, my sons know about this game. They're very excited about the new version coming out. And Tony shared with us a little bit about just the music
that's part of it. Yeah, it has an amazing soundtrack and it features a variety of new skate parks. They added a water park. So cool. By the way, if you haven't seen the HBO documentary until the wheels come off about Tony Hawk, it is incredible.
Incredible. It is all about his life and career. It was made by the amazing Sam Jones. It features tons of interviews from different skateboarders, from members of the Bones Brigade, which is the skateboarding group he skated with when he was younger. It's gonna be a great two hours of your life.
Highly recommend. So great. Josh had seen it a while back and he was like, before we even knew Tony was gonna be on, he was like, Ang, this is a great documentary. You've gotta watch it. And there's also just so much footage of Tony growing up.
You really realize how much skateboarding, how much of his life it spans since he was nine years old. I also really loved how the documentary got into his relationship with his father and the way that his father was so supportive of his skateboarding. It was something that he had that not a lot of skateboarding kids have.
And it was really cool. So you guys, we were really nervous to interview Tony because like we said, he is one of the greatest athletes of all time. He is a total legend, but he was so wonderful and we had such a nice time talking to him. We're so excited to share this interview with you. I mean, I still can't believe it really happened.
I can either. But let's take a break and when we come back, it's our interview with Tony Hawk. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Lady, did you know that workplace stress is now one of the top causes of declining mental health with 61% of the global workforce experiencing higher than normal levels of stress? I did not know that. Well, we can't just say goodbye to these things, you know?
We can't just say goodbye to work, but you can start a focus on wellness. Yes, and that focus on wellness can come in many forms. It can be for me taking a walk. You could reach out to a therapist on BetterHelp. With over 35,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform. They've served over 5 million people globally. It's convenient too. You can join a session with a therapist at the click of a button. As the largest online therapy provider in the world,
BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Unwind from work with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash Office Ladies. That's BetterHelp, H-E-l-p, dot com slash office ladies. Hey, I'm Ben Stiller. And I'm Adam Scott.
And we host a podcast called the Severance Podcast, where we used to break down every episode of the TV show Severance. Severance isn't back just yet, but the podcast is. Each week we'll discuss the movies, TV shows, and ideas that influence the making of Severance. We're going to talk to the incredible artists who inspire us to do what we do. The Severance podcast returns Thursday, June 26. Follow and listen everywhere you get your podcasts. Hello! Hi! Tony Hawk! I'm here. In the studio at Office Ladies. Can't believe it. Well, I can't either.
I mean, I'm excited. I can't believe it because it was on my calendar for a while. And then I also rescheduled. I apologize. No, we are so excited. Thank you. Jenna and I are both just trying to play it cool because we're really big fans. I mean, you're kind of a bigger than life person for us.
And so this is really amazing. Oh, I appreciate it. You guys are legends and part of the world. I mean, you're kind of a bigger than life person for us. And so this is really amazing. Oh, I appreciate it. You guys are legends and part of a TV legacy that I don't think will ever be topped. Truly. It's unreal. I mean, we're like, I'm speechless. To have those words come out of your mouth is just like so crazy.
Oh, honestly, I mean, I'll jump right into it, but I watched it obviously from day one. And then when my daughter got to be the age where she appreciated it, COVID hit, and we just went all the way through from the very beginning to the end. And it was a really special time to share with my daughter. Yeah.
Because it was, you know, COVID, school, stuff in your room, everything. And that was something that we did every day. It was really cool. So thank you. Because it was, you know, COVID, school, stuff in your room, everything. And that was something that we did every day. It was really cool. So thank you. So you watched it when it was originally on, but then you recently did the whole binge. Well, is that recent now?
2020? Recent-ish? Right. Don't, let's, I don't know about my retainment of knowledge, but yeah, it was pretty recent. I mean, we heard you were a super fan of The Office. There is a Reddit thread called Tony Hawk as a fan of The Office. I think you- Really?
Yes. Yes. I guess you said in an interview one time, oh, how the turntable turns or something. Oh, yes. And everyone like jumped on that. Yes. It started a thread. Oh, how the turntables.
Yes, exactly. That's it. You didn't even know the quote. I did, I got it wrong. I always get it wrong. Well, I have an office related question for you. If you could only watch one episode for the rest of your life.
I knew this was coming. What would you pick? Okay, I was gonna go for the low hanging fruit of Booze Cruise. That's a very good choice. Yes, and then my wife and I recently watched Casino Night. Oh, that's a good one. So good.
That was it. That was my choice. Oh no, no. I take it back. I'm sorry. We watched Casino Night and then we realized, dinner party. Dinner party is the best. You're naming three, like, of the top episodes.
Okay, but dinner Party was the absurdity and the idea that you get to see them and their element and their living space, that was the best. Yeah. That was one of the most fun episodes that Jenna and I did. And I mean, we loved the show.
We loved the conference room scenes and party planning committee and just all of it. Oh no, with their house. But Dinner Party, walking into Michael and Jan's condo, you can't unsee that. That lives with their house. But dinner party, like walking into Michael and Jan's condo, like you can't unsee that. Yes. That lives with you forever. Yeah. What was the first episode you ever saw of The Office?
Do you remember? I saw it in the beginning. So I learned about The Office, I mean, not to brag or anything, but I was in London doing a bunch of interviews and press for our video game around 2002-ish, maybe 2003. And the two guys that were assigned to take me around all the UK press were from the same area where the UK office was shot. Okay. Okay.
And they're like, you have to watch the show. It defines our work life. It is exactly what happens. And Richard Gervais is amazing. Steven Murchett, like you have to do it. And by the time that I was done with this week-long, whatever, journey in the UK, they gave me
the DVD. Of the UK office. And so I watched that for the rest of the trip and on the way home. Got hooked on it. I went through it was only two seasons, right? Yeah. Yeah. So I went through both seasons. In fact, I was still watching it as the second season was coming out. And the next thing I know, they're like, they're doing the US.
You know, same producers. And Steve Crow and I was like, awesome. So from day one. So you were okay with this US remake? Because a lot of people who absolutely love the British show, they were concerned. They thought maybe is America going to ruin it? But as an American, I appreciated the references a lot more.
Yeah, that's true, right? Yeah. And the UK one, I mean, this one too, but the UK one was pretty raunchy. I mean, definitely. Which I loved. They did not have network standards and practices breathing dumb. They're next, for sure. Good for them.
Yes. We had to blur out and bleep a lot of stuff. We definitely did. It was like a constant conversation. Like when Phyllis gets flashed in the parking lot, I think standards and practices said we could only say penis 13 times in the whole episode. And we blew that in the cold open or something. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, that's the that's the um jackass approach. It's just bombard them. Right away. So that they come back to some place where you probably would have ended up anyway. Right, exactly. Okay, this is kind of a cheesy question but we were curious. What character from the office do you think you're most like? I think I'm an amalgamation of various characters. Okay.
I love food as much as Kevin loves food. I love Stanley's approach to no nonsense. He's over it. He's just riding it out. Like, I feel like I'm kind of doing that. Like, I'm not gonna take any more bullsh**. I'm not gonna do every opportunity. And it's just more like, I'm doing this because I love it. And when it's over, it's over.
You know what I mean? Yeah. Yeah. He's not he's not a go-getter. He's a run out the clock. Running out the clock. I get a little bit of that. You know what I mean? At my age.
I hope that I have a fun approach to life like Jim. So I feel like I'm sort of a cross of all those characters. And no Dwight, no Angela, no Pam. have a fun approach to life like Jim. So I feel like I'm sort of a cross of all those characters. No Dwight, no Angela, no Pam. I'm kidding. Yeah, maybe just Dwight in that I do have a deep-seated nerd in me from when I was a kid. I was a nerdy math kid and skinny kid and didn't fit in,
but I found skateboarding. so it's in there somewhere. Dwight's still trying to get out. Right, right. A big thing on The Office are the pranks between Jim and Dwight. Yes. Is there pranking in the skateboard world? Not really.
No. I mean, just maybe a little bit, but, you know, what we do requires such, such intense focus and physicality. Yeah. You don't really want to mess with that. So I can't think of any amazing pranks. There was one time a guy...
This was a pretty sh-t prank though. It was during a really heated practice session in the 80s and only a very specific core of skateboarders would know what this is. But this one photographer who was known to be just kind of full of hijinks, he went up to the ramp and went to jump in to the practice session. He could skate, but he wasn't a competitor by any means.
And he had blood bags in his knees, in his knee pads. And then he fell and he started writhing around agony and there's just pools of blood coming out of his knees. That's not cool. Who wants that? That was the point. Who wants that? I'm not gonna say, I'm not gonna say.
Also, you know where my mind goes immediately. First of all, like people seriously get injured and then that's like scary part of skateboarding. People were losing it. My dad was actually one of the organizers of this one event because he helped to found, he helped to organize the National Skateboard Association in the 80s, there was no sanctioning bodies of skate events.
My dad was pissed. I bet, I bet. Also, my mind goes to this place, which is sort of like the mom and me of like, now who's gonna clean that up? Cause now everyone can't skate. Cause all that crap is on the- Well, so it's funny you say that.
So that event, I had to come in late cause we were on a different skate trip. So I didn't see it happen. But when I came the next morning, there's just this giant red stain on the ramp. Like, what the hell is that? And they're like, oh my God, you know what? So and so did this.
And then as soon as people started to realize it was fake, he got up and ran away. He better run away. Yeah. Oh my gosh. Well, you know, people ask us as actors, like if there's a lot of pranking going on on sets. And we especially get that question
because of these pranking storylines. But the answer is I have never been on a set with a major prank. I was pranked once on the set of The Office by John Krasinski in the whole nine years. There was this scene where we're riding up to Shroot Farms in this car and it was really hot out. It was a hot day and we would have to turn off the air
conditioner for sound. And I was so hot and we were dressed for fall. And I was so hot and I was like, oh my God, I'm dying. I was so hot and we were dressed for fall. And I was so hot and I was like, oh my God, I'm dying. I was so hot. Are you hot? And he's like, I'm okay. The whole time he had turned my seat heater on. That's it.
That's my one office prank. So crazy. But if I look cranky in that scene, it's cause I was really hot. Is that when you guys were going to spend the night there? I think it was when we were going there for the bed and breakfast. Right, because Mo's is like running alongside the car. Yes.
Yeah, we didn't do pranks. We took, it's like a serious job and everything's choreographed and you're aware that like time is money and you're like on a schedule. But we did sometimes mess with each other a little bit with improv and dialogue. And mine was when Mo's kidnaps Angela for the wedding, and I'm in the trunk of the car, I said to our director, when they open the car, can she just like really cuss them out? And he was like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He was like, I'm not gonna tell the guys, just let them have it. And they opened the trunk and I'm like, what the fuck is your problem? So if you watch that scene, John Krasinski's reaction, he's really like, what the hell? What are you doing? That was real.
That's perfect. I have a technical question for you. Sure. Okay. So we had an office episode that had parkour. Yeah. Have you ever parkour? No. What's the difference?
Anytime I do anything that resembles it, I say parkour. Yeah. Have you ever parkour? No. What's the difference? Exactly. Anything that resembles it, I say parkour. You do? Of course. Yes. Who doesn't? Right. I know. We just did a stunt with a parkour export.
Okay. And he goes by Dom Tomato on social medias. And we, Annie McDonald, who's also a pro skateboarder, he and I do a lot of choreography together. Where one goes over the other person. Yeah, yeah. We did a lot of X games like that. We won a few medals and this guy said,
hey, do you think you could do something with me in the mix? And it was one of the only times where I've been a little trepidatious when I finally got there and I was seeing what we're going to do. Like this could go- All the things you've done, wow. It could go really bad either for him or me. Right. Andy was the one who was going over. So basically what happened was, you know, we're on a half pipe and he's going over me.
I'm grinding along the top and this guy is running from the back of the deck and he jumps through our over under space, which is tight already. And then we have a stunt pad for him at the bottom of the ramp. So he is going the exact opposite direction that anyone should be going in this situation. Meaning that if he hit me, I'm ejecting to the bottom of the ramp. And on his first attempt, his stomach hit my helmet. And that wasn't, didn't inspire confidence. You know? And so we watched it back and I said, look, I'm going to be low as low as I can. You have more room. Get closer to Andy.
Yeah. Be higher. Be a little higher. Yeah. And it worked? It worked. Yeah. Well, you brought up kind of the idea of getting injured and injury is a part of skateboarding. Yes. You've been injured many times. I broke my shoulder two years ago
and my life has never been the same. How do you, how have you healed from so many injuries? Cause I mean, I still can't put my arm, the range of motion and I've done all the things. Like how do you heal? Well, it's not always full healing and we learn to adapt. That's my best answer. You work around your injuries.
Yeah, like, well, I broke my femur three years ago and that was definitely the most traumatic injury that I had and in my 50s, so didn't help the healing process, but I've kind of lost some techniques. They're nuanced. They're ones that are bittersweet for me to lose, but at the same time, I still get to do what I do. I'm still skating in a professional level,
so I just have to accept that. But through the years, yeah, I mean, like, if you see this shoulder, this kind of drops here. I separated the shoulder about 10 years ago, and that's what it is. It still works. I think that because what we do is, we require such intense motion
that we end up kind of getting back there by default. Okay. Do you have like a warmup routine? Like, do you have to- I do now. I used to not. I used to just go in cold Turkey and do all the stuff and I didn't really care.
And then I f***ed around and found out I can't really do that when I'm in this age. So I now I do, I have a warmup routine. I actually do strength training, workout three times a week besides skating. And that's how I'm able to do it at this level at this age. And what about like a cool down? Do you do cold dips or stretches after?
I have one, but it's really hard to get motivated. Uh huh. So she does cold dips. I can't do it. I can't get in there. Rainn Wilson does too. Rainn and I both love our cold dips. Every day? Almost every day. In the morning? No, now I do them at night, but I also do contrast hydrotherapy. So I sit in hot water for three minutes.
And then I sit in cold water for one minute and I go back and forth and I end on cold. And I do them at night before bed because they help me with my hot flashes, all my menopause ladies out there, hot tip, the cold dipping really helps. I tried it and it made me so angry. Like I got in that cold water and I was like,
this is stupid, I don't like this. The thing I don't like about it is you can't move. Cause when you move, you feel it more intensely. It's more cold, yeah. Yeah. So you get in and you're like, okay, I'm stuck in this position. That's it for whatever, three minutes, I don't know,
five minutes. Yeah, I'm not a fan. Oh, I do one minute. Oh, one minute. I just do one minute. Maybe that was my problem. And you go back and forth. That's why I didn't like it that much.
Me too, I don't know. I don't know. No, it's more, and I have been encouraged to do it by many experts, so I should probably get back to it. We have a plunge, so maybe I should be doing that again. Okay, would you do an office quiz with us? Oh, yes, okay. You're saying that like you think we're going to be good at it, but we aren't. I mean, I already got the turntables
wrong. Can I have my daughter on a lifeline? Yes. Yes, you can. I told her, I said, I know you're going to be in this, she's doing finals this week, but I was like, where will you be around noon tomorrow? Yeah. Cause I'm doing, she's like, you're doing office ladies? I said, yeah. And I go, why? I have to call you for a question doing, she's like, you're doing office ladies? I said, yeah. And I go, well, I might have to call you for a question. She's like, okay, I'll try to answer. Okay. But I'm not, only if I'm desperate. She can be your hotline. So, Cassie, our producer, put together this quiz. We don't know the questions. She pulled them without our knowledge. Oh, they're for all of us. They're for all of us. We're going to play each other. We're going head to head. I've already misquoted a quote you knew, so don't be intimidated.
All right. Okay. All right. Are you ready? Yes. Are we going to say, dang or buzz? I guess I can't really call my daughter if we're on the time crunch. Oh, you can put her on speaker.
Or Tony, you can call and have her on with you. Like it could be the two of you against us. Yes, we're fine with that. All right, let's try that. Actually, maybe she'll win. She could be the fourth contestant. Maybe she'll win. If we get her.
Funky Town. She might call back. Okay. Love it. If she calls back, I'll put her on. Okay, perfect. All might call back. Okay. Love it. If she calls back, I'll put her on. Okay. Sounds good.
Perfect. All right. Here we go. Question one. In the Happy Hour episode, what was the name of the book that Michael said he wrote in his head? Oh, God. Ding.
Is it Somehow I Manage? That is correct. Wow. His management book. I didn't know it was from that episode. Somehow I manage? That is correct. Wow. His management book. I didn't know it was from that episode. I was gonna go threat level midnight cause I just feel like that's the default answer
for anything. For anything he's written. I had nothing. In Phyllis's wedding, what color dress did Kelly wear to the wedding? White. White. Ding. Oh, dang it. We did it wrong, Tony.
Yeah, ding. But we, that's a tie. Ding white. Ding white. We both, that's a tie. A point for each of you. Okay, okay. In the Coup episode, what was the fictitious name of Dwight's dentist? Ding, ding.
Cringtest. That is correct. Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! In the threat level midnight episode, who does Golden Face kill in the movie? Ding! Oh, I mean it's Oscar, right? No. Oh!
Oh, nice. Which office character does Golden Face kill? Ding. Tony. Creed? No. That was a distinction. I'll give you a hint.
Oh wait, no, I'll ding. Oh, Toby? Toby, yes, yes. Oh, of course it's Toby. Yes. I just, you know what I remembered is the stunt and that head they had to create. Yes. I was like, I'm in the scene.
Yes. I think I'm in the scene when he kills someone. I'm sitting on the floor with Troy. Of course, if Michael wrote it, Toby dies. Of course. Of course. Of course. That was a no-brainer. Dang it.
OK. All right, here's an easy one. In the Goodbye Michael episode, who went to the airport to say goodbye to Michael? Ding. Ding. Damn. Me.
All right, everyone gets a point. Yay. In the promos episode, who was leaving Andy mean comments under the screen name Texas Poon Tapa? Ding. Nellie. Correct. Oh, I was not going to... I wasn't going to find that. Yeah, no.
That was good, Angie. In the viewing party episode, Erin and Gabe hosted a viewing party for what TV show? Oh, crap. Ding the one with the singing in it. And it's, uh, it's Glee. Oh, ding, no, yeah! Oh my gosh.
You know what? I saw that on one of the episode descriptions yesterday. I just flashed it in my head. Like that was, had I read it more closely, I could have got it. In the work bust episode, who was the hitchhiker Dwight picked up on the side of the road?
Ding, Creed. Ah. All right, this next one, there are three answers. So I'll give you a point for each person. Oh. Oh. In the employee transfer episode, which three employees dressed as the Joker for Halloween? Ding.
Kevin, Creed. Oh, who was the third one? Someone else can ding in. Ding Dwight, yeah, I was gonna say. Ding Dwight, right? Yeah, Dwight. I'll give it to Tony. I get two of them though.
Yes, you do. Angela, you're crushing it. It's almost like you're on the show. In Andy's Auntcha Street, Yes, you do. Angela, you're crushing it. It's almost like you're on the show. In Andy's Aunt's Street, who did Nellie say he was related to? Ding, Michelle Obama. Correct. Final question. In the Survivor Man episode, when did Michael schedule Toby's birthday party? Be seeing. Never? No, he did schedule it.
He did? Yes. On some horrible day in history? No. Here's a hint, Tony. What would be like the worst time to throw a birthday party during the work week? On, I don't know, ding Monday?
Oh, I think you almost had it. Ding Friday night, what? Close, 4.58 PM on Friday. Oh, that's it, okay. I did not remember that at all. Making them stay, yeah. Yes, okay. That was a hard quiz, Cassie.
Okay, how did we do? I think Angela Kinsey might've won. Tony had three points, Jenna had five, and Angela had seven. Wow. Wow. I get a little competitive in board games, Tony. Was that a board game? I don't know what it was.
Any game. Any game. Any game. That's okay. So would my daughter have, so I feel like it, it wouldn't have been fun, but it's okay. Sorry, KK, I tried. If she calls back though, she can be bonus round. So for her birthday, I'm on Cameo, by the way. Oh yeah?
For her birthday, a few years ago, I got every office character on Cameo. So I had this like seven minute happy birthday from, almost, you know, most everyone. We are not on Cameo, but we will do a video for her. I appreciate that. We absolutely will. Yes, we will. And we. And for her birthday is next month.
Any niece or nephew or grandchild in the future. OK, thank you. Yes, I have a grandchild. Yeah, you do. Yeah. Well, you can call that in any time. How old is your grandchild? Eight months. Oh, that's the cutest, most cutie patootie age. He's so funny. Makes like funny faces. Well, yeah. the cutest, most cutie-patootie age of...
He's so funny. Makes like funny faces. Well, yeah. And also when he comes to our house, he knows it's just fun time. Yeah. So as soon as he crosses the threshold, the smile comes on his face and he sees, my wife is Momo and I'm Papa. He sees Momo and Papa and he's like, oh, okay.
It's my time. Party time. Yeah. There's no rules. Oh my gosh. That is so sweet. It's part-time. Yeah, there's no rules. Oh my gosh, that is so sweet. It's so fun. It's so cute. It's so fun. Before we start this section, I just want you to know that Jen and I watched so many videos of you skating.
There are so many, Tony. Oh, well thank you. I mean, so many, Tony. You have been like- Oh, well thank you. I mean, it's just amazing. Your whole life is amazing. I'm just super old, so I've been doing it a long time. No, we're the same age, I think. I think you and I are the same age.
I'll be 54 in June. We're not the same age. Oh. That's okay. We're close though. You're very close. I'm honored that you think I'm 54. Oh.
Well, anyway, we're very excited to talk to you about skateboarding, although we're probably the least qualified to ask you these questions. Yes, and I know these are questions that you've probably answered many times, but I think that for our listeners, this might be like very new. So we're excited. Thank you. Sure.
So everyone knows you for doing the first 900. This is a trick that took you like seven years to master. Or more? More, yeah, yes, but. But you've also invented over 100 tricks in your career. Do you have a personal favorite that you've ever done or invented? Yeah, you know, I learned how to do an ollie 540,
which is basically a one and a half spin in the air without grabbing the board around 1989. And I tried that trick as a joke. I literally did it, was like, haha, look at it, crazy, no handed. And then at some point figured out how to sort of scoop the board using my feet and keep it on during the rotation. And I think that's probably the one that I'm most proud of because
I felt like it unlocked a new direction and a new way to keep your board on your feet. It also looks like magic when you do it. It just, I was like, how is it there? The wild part is that there is a whole new generation of skating, of skaters that have figured out how to take that to new heights. And there are literally skaters doing ollie 540s like seven or eight feet above the ramp. I did it right at the top of the ramp because I couldn't figure out
how to keep my board on my feet any longer. And they've just unlocked this whole new technique that I love that I get to witness it. When you were doing the 900 trick, was there a moment, because you did it, you did so many attempts. Was there a moment? Well, many, many, many before that, yes.
Many, many, yeah. Was there a moment where you saw it? Was there a moment where it just clicked for you that it made it that one time different than all the other times? There was, but that happened years prior to when I, when I actually figured it out. To the X Games?
Yeah. There was a moment where I thought, if I really just commit to this, it should work. And this is around 1994, maybe 95. And I committed to a landing, to be honest, the reason that I was committing to landing is because I was running out of time to skate because I had to go pick up my son at preschool.
This is not a joke. Like, you know, my son was going to be the last kid at preschool waiting. So you had to figure it out. So I got to like try to make this stupid trick so I can get out of here and get there on time. And so I just said, okay, this is it. I'm committing to it. And when I, when I went to commit to it, I was leaning too far forward on the landing and I crashed into the bottom of the ramp and broke my rib.
Still managed to get my son, you know, with a cracked rib. With a broken rib. Yeah. I mean, this is mid 90s skateboarding. We didn't have a lot of resources or support. And I was just doing this because I loved it. You know, ESPN was not going to show up there. Show up there and be like, hey, he did a 900. They didn't even know what a 900 was. This was sort of the dark days of skateboarding,
especially of ramp skating. So long story short, in that moment, I thought maybe it doesn't work because I had all the pieces to the puzzle. I envisioned making it and I fell forward and got hurt. So picked up my son, healed up, whatever. And then I kind of put it on the shelf. Tried it, waffled on every once in a while,
but I could never get my, I could never commit to it again in the way that I did that one day, because I didn't want to break my rib again. Or my collar, I thought my collarbone was broken because it was so high up. Luckily it was just a rib. But so when I was at the X Games
and I was starting to get close, I just thought, you know what, if I'm ever going to get hurt again, it'll be here. It's here. Yeah. I don't mind. I'll take one for the sake of trying to finally get it again. And so when I did try to land it the first time at X Games, I fell forward. It's all there documented, but I didn't get hurt.
And that was the moment that I figured it out. Because I thought, if I can shift my weight, mid-spin more to my back foot, I won't fall forward. And so the next attempt, I shifted my weight to my back foot and then I fell backwards. And it was like, that's the light bulb. That was the epiphany. And I just had to even that out.
Yeah, and the next one worked. It's really dramatic when you watch it. And the thing that was so moving to me is how the crowd is with you the whole entire time. Yeah, that was wild. I mean, I think I feel... And the other skaters are coming around there, like almost laying hands on you and like banging their boards.
Yeah. But I do feel like that is a slice of what skateboarding is. Skateboarding is this really supportive community, even though it's an individual pursuit, even though we do compete, there's a brethren and there's a kindred spirit of everyone just loves doing it and loves being part of the scene.
If you go to a skate park right now, there'll be people of all ages, all races, all genders, just enjoying the space and cheering each other on. So I just feel like that was such a great, and I'm honored that it was me, but whoever it had been, it was a great example of what skateboarding is all about. It was so beautiful. I mean, after you landed it, the other skaters,
they like all pile on you like you see players at the World Series piling on each other. And when I watched that video, Angela, I don't know if this popped in your head, but it reminded me of the night that Steve Carell won the Golden Globe for playing Michael Scott. Oh, my gosh. So great. And it was totally unexpected.
We did not think he was going to win. And he won. And when he walked into the party holding that trophy, the whole cast piled onto him. That's so cool. And it was that feeling where it was like, well, I didn't win the Golden Globe. But we did.
But we won it because he won it. You would have thought we had emerged. Yes, you won that for, you landed that for the whole community. Yeah. And you, it was so beautiful. It's so true. We weren't even invited to the Golden Globes, the cast.
We were in a garage parking lot annex next to the building that they had put a tent over. Wow. And we were with all these suits. Just watching it on TV screens. The suits are very, the business side of the world and they're very sort of like, oh, just sitting there proper. And when we won, or Steve won, we lost it in this garage and we were waiting
for him and he let us all hold it. I hit Phyllis in the face with it by accident in a group photo, but that's exactly what it was like. It felt like you won it for everybody. Oh, for sure. Yeah. And there was just with that trick, there were a few of us that have been trying it for years. And at some point it was like someone just do it already. You know what I mean? It wasn't even like we were in competition with each other. It was just like this has to be done just so we can prove it's possible. And now it's, it's something that young kids do. It's wild. Not many.
Not many, but, but it has become a little more standardized. And also the ramps and facilities have gotten bigger. So, and there's resources, there's foam pits, there's all kinds of things that you can do to work up to this. I had to do it the hard knocks. Literally hard knocks. Yeah. I did read that if you create a trick,
you get to name it. Is that true? For the most part, it's a little tricky now because there are so many variations of moves that it's kind of like, look, just cause you did a shove it out of that, you don't get to claim that.
Doesn't mean it's yours. Yeah. Yeah. But, but yes, but especially back in the day, that's why we have all these absurd names. Right. We were looking up a few. All right, here's a question for you.
Is there a skater past or present that you think maybe gets overlooked that deserves to be, have more of their story told or legendary status? Yeah, several for sure. I mean, to offer a deep cut, there was a guy named David Zee when Kevin and I were younger,
and he was the first person we ever saw truly fly high with ease and with style, even before Christian Osoy. And he was just in the right place at the wrong time. It was just the deadest time of skating. He was a little older, so we had to find a job and just wasn't in the cards. David Zee, it's even hard to find photos of him. But I would say in terms of
my influences, a guy named Eddie Alguera, he was the most innovative skater when I was coming up through the ranks. And people gave him a hard time because they said he didn't have style and he was all about tricks and he's like a robotic and I was young and I didn't have style and I wanted to do tricks. So I watched everything he did. His signature moves were my first advanced moves. That's so cool. So there were a lot of times when skateboarding went away or went out of fashion and it wasn't paying the bills, you kind of went through a lot of these droughts.
It really reminds me of the lifestyle of an actor where you have a show or you're doing a movie, but then you're gonna have a couple years where you're auditioning, but you can't get hired. You had to find a lot of creative ways to stay in the business. Can you talk a little bit about that? Yeah. Yeah, we had a wave of success in the late 80s,
and we were young and naive enough to think that that was never going to end. Mm-hmm. So we were spending as if that was happening. And I had two homes. I had one with these giant ramps set up. And suddenly I found myself with my income kind of dropping by half every month because it was all royalty based and people just weren't buying my skateboards or you know my shoe sponsor was like, oh we gotta cut your salary again. We just cut it last month.
Okay. And so I just did whatever I could to make ends meet. I, at one point I had a really basic editing system which no one had. This is probably 92, 93 ish. So people didn't really have that kind of stuff. So I just was getting odd jobs editing stuff on three quarter tape. Wow. Not even skateboard related? Some not skateboard related, mostly skateboard related. Any company that wanted to do their skate video needed to master it.
They could do it in my garage. Oh, wow. And I could do it for them. I mean, I got, you know, maybe a hundred bucks to do it or whatever it was, but I got by. And then I started getting hired. Luckily, I had made enough connections in Hollywood that I started getting hired as a consultant on any shoot that was, that had skateboarding in it. Because I was 24 and considered too old to be the featured skateboarder.
You know, it was more the narrative was, it's for teenagers and whatever. So I would go to a set and explain what is possible in whatever the landscape was. And that worked. It was cool. I mean, I got to be in skating, but it was tricky. Yeah, it was, there were some lean times. I was definitely eating a lot of Taco Bell those days.
Yeah, we talk about this a lot too, like even within our careers. Sometimes you just have to like see the pivot and take it. You know? Yeah. Oh, I was going to fight to the death to not get a real job. Yeah.
I mean, they were real jobs. Yeah, yeah. I'm just talking about like just going nine to five, whatever it was like, I gotta have something else. Right, and something's still in the world of skating. So now you're on a set. It really was just more, whatever allowed me to keep skating.
I didn't even care about being a pro or being in the magazines or whatever. I just wanted to keep skating. Yeah, I think that's so relatable for us because all we wanna do is create. You know, that's like what makes us happy. Right. And so you just follow that wherever anyone will let you do that.
Yeah. Yeah, exactly. Oh, at one point, I'll tell you how I survived really in those days was rollerblade shows because rollerblading was huge. Yeah. Right. It's the early 90s. Everyone's, you know, just on the street, whatever. And there were a bunch of people that skated Halfpipe. And so they had these rollerblade shows all on the street, whatever. And there were a bunch of people that skated half pipe.
And so they had these roller blade shows all over the place, like Team Rollerblade Live, inline shows at Magic Mountain. And I got to be the special guest skateboarder of these shows. And that paid my bills probably for a whole year. How do you maintain your mental health through those droughts? I think I just focused in on my strengths and realized like living the dream just morphed into
being able to skate. So for instance, the tourists before that we were, we were flying to Europe and we had a, you know, we had a big van and we had these huge crowds. And then it became there's six of us in our delivery van and we're all gonna share one room and we're going to skate whatever ramps they set up in the parking lot for us, but we're still skating. So I had to just keep it in perspective. And yeah, it sucked.
It was hot and I was rolling my ankles left and right. And I'm in charge, like I'm only 25 and I'm in charge. Like, I'm the tour manager of this chaos, you know? But all along, we got to skate. And so that's how I kept my mental health in check. If I was unable to skate, then I would start kind of losing it. I think it's pretty amazing what your game has brought to the skating community as well. So my sons, they don't know how to skateboard, but they love your games.
Oh, so cool. They love Tony Hawk Pro Skater. And they were so excited that I was meeting you today. And we meet like really great people all the time. And they're like, oh, yeah, that's cool. And I said your name, they're like, no way. And they were like, are you serious? And I guess you have a big game that's coming out July 11th, like the three and four they told me. So that's- Wow, so they did my own press for me.
They did your, they were like, no, there's a new game coming out. They have my talking points. They do. I went and looked up the date. They didn't know the date, but they're like, no, there's a new one coming out. Yeah, hey, just the fact that they know that
is a big deal to me. Yeah? Yeah, because we've been working for a while on that, and it's been really hard to contain the secret. So we finally got to reveal it last week. Oh, wow. Yeah, no, they know. I think they follow gamers, you know? Okay.
So when things are announced. Yeah, we did an event, a lot of influencers were there. A lot of the bands that are featured in the game were there. A lot of the bands that are featured in the game were there. A lot of the characters that are featured in the game were there. So I'm glad it came across their radar. Yeah. Can you say some of the bands that were there? Sure.
Urethane is one of the bands. Steve Cavallaro's Pro Skater is actually in that band. The Adolescents, who did songs like Amoeba and Kids of the Black Hole. You've heard them, but you probably don't know what that is. Danny Brown is hip-hop artist from Detroit, and Lupe Fiasco who famously has the kick push song about skateboarding. I just know how much music is a part of the skateboarding culture as well. I was telling you that my very first boyfriend was a skateboarder. Yes. My high school love of my life. And I spent two or three years at skate parks.
Oh wow. What city? Watching him skate. St. Louis. I was a skate Betty. I don't know if we're still allowed to call ourselves skate Betty's. That's pretty cool. That's OG. That's right. I wore the t-shirts and dressed in the gear. When you say you wore the t-shirts, what in the gear and you say you wore the t-shirts What does that mean like a thrasher t-shirt? Yeah, like probably in those days, you know, maybe black flag Black flag world industries. I don't remember
Yeah, what years I would have been there. So this, I guess, which I didn't realize, in St. Louis, Missouri, nobody told us there was a skateboarding drought during, like, 88 to 91. Yeah. I mean, we were like, it was in full force, and all these guys would go out there on the halfpipe, and they'd be trying to do the stuff, and... Did you ever go to a halfpipe that was plexiglass? Do you remember? Like it was see-through?
I don't think so. in St. Louis, no. Because there was a half pipe in St. Louis that was portable that I skated many times in those years. Wow, I don't think so. I think I would have remembered that. One of the parks we went to was, I guess, is this called a bowl? Where it's cement.
And then there were other like wooden half pipes or quarter pipes or whatever. Yeah, I mean, and it was, I loved those guys. Really creative. Good guys. Just kind of doing their own thing. Yes. And not caring what anyone thinks.
No. And it made me want to ask you what part of skateboarding culture do you think has been most misunderstood or misrepresented by the mainstream? I think it's more the misfit aspect in that they want to focus on these are outcasts or that they're troublemakers. And it's like, no, they're just doing their own thing. And they're doing it in a highly creative way. And I feel like skateboarding teaches you so much about how to solve problems, how to be self-motivated and instill self-confidence, like maybe nothing else in your life.
And it makes you see, it's just this great equalizer, but it's very inclusive. So you just get to hang out with all kinds of different people, but you have the shared interest and an immediate bond. I totally agree. And I think like, I mean, I know that when I brought my skateboarding boyfriend home for the first time with his like blue hair and his like crazy way
that he dressed and his like, you know, slouchy clothes and all this stuff, I know that my parents were a little bit like, huh, okay. Okay, cause I was going to like a private Catholic girls school and you know, they were always the mixers with the private boys schools and all that. Like those were the like dances
that you were encouraged to go to. And I was like, I don't know what to tell you guys, but you know, those prep school boys, they got nothing on the skater boys. Like they are, because also the skaters were not slackers or delinquents or any of that. They're disciplined. Yeah, very disciplined. I mean, listen, if you want to date a skater,
be prepared to sit at a skate park for like hours watching them try a trick because- And nursing wounds. Yes. I mean, a couple of broken wrists and things. Not just from falling, but from like a board hitting. I mean, that was how my boyfriend broke his wrist was like his board flipped up and then cranked
and then the rest. Oh, wow. Yeah. That's rough. That is, that's literally insult injury. It really is. It really, really is. Yeah. So I just, I think it's a cool thing. And I think that it's really, really cool
that through your foundation, you have the skate park project where you have helped fund something like over 600 skate parks around the world. One in St. Louis actually. And one in St. Louis. That is so cool. Yeah, I got to go to the grand opening of that one.
It was cool. That's so great. Well, I'm a dinosaur cause I'm gonna just tell you that you that I grew up roller skating. I still roller skate. My roller skates are... Clods? Yes.
Old school. Clods are cool, man. Yeah. I grew up in Indonesia. So I got my first pair through the Sears catalog. It took six months to get there. But the pair I still skate with, I have three pairs by the front door. I got in Redondo Beach in like 94,
but they're still my favorite. But there are skate parks that have the smaller like little hills and stuff like that. And we would go and try to do, you know, whatever, just pop back on your back four, jump a little thing, like really small things. But it was such a way to de-stress for me. And it still is.
And I have outdoor wheels, those are my favorite. I don't really like indoor skating as much. It's, I like to be outside. Outdoor, they're more like skateboard wheels. Yeah, they're bigger. But I just find it as a way to just sort of check out of my mind and get into my body. I mean, that's why I continue to do it
against all odds and through injuries. Yeah. That's my zen for sure, but I think it's cool. And that's why I continue to do it against all odds and through injuries. That's my zen for sure. But I think it's cool you do quads. They're making a huge comeback. There's quite a faction of young girls that are starting to do quads skating at skateparks these days. Well, I almost brought him in today and my husband was like, no, don't meet Tony on roller
skates. That's too dorky. No, I love it. I've got another question. What life skills does skateboarding build that you can't learn in a classroom? Yeah, I think discipline in a way that is much more intense and much more self-projected, where it's not someone telling you,
you gotta do this, do these reps. It's like, you just gotta get just got to get up and try. You just got to keep trying and getting up and persistence. And I think, I think probably the one thing skating taught me through all my years is to embrace failure because that's how I'm going to learn. And that's how I'm going to figure these other things out. And even like breaking my rib, doing 900, I am glad I did that because that led me to actually figure the whole thing out.
Put a stall in my efforts a little bit, but it's more like that. It's that you needed those failures to either learn or to keep yourself in reality. Because not everything's gonna win. Not every show is gonna to be The Office. Well, tell me about it. Or none. No shows are going to be The Office.
I mean, our overnight success was each of us about nine years. Nine years of just out there just doing anything we could. So great. Yeah. Well, this has just been so great. Is there anything you want to ask us, The Office related? Yeah. I mean, what, what is it like to, I just can't think of any other TV shows
barring say the Simpsons or, you know, something that happened in the seventies or eight, like Cheers, what's it like to have a TV show that's so iconic? It is, it's a meme factory. Yeah. Still. Yeah. I get sent myself.
All the time. For people. But is it hard for you guys to exist in the real world in that sense? It is not hard for me to exist in the real world. I feel like I have such an identity outside of that job and outside of the fame of that job. And I'm so grateful because I love to travel, that I can go to any kind of like iconic sort of like tourist attraction and I don't get like overly recognized or bothered or anything.
Like I can go up in the Eiffel Tower. Like I think of like, can Taylor Swift, she can't just go up in the Eiffel Tower, right? Or Jennifer Aniston can't just go up in the Eiffel Tower if she's in Paris. And so I feel so grateful that I can do those things. You can live a relatively normal life. I can. I can. And so I do. Yeah. To me, it's just all like abundant universe kind of stuff, you know? It's just, I look back on it and like, wow, that was so cool. I'm so glad I got to do that.
And then I'm so grateful that I get to continue just working with my best friend. And we journeyed a lot of that together. And that's been a huge amount of support because we started the office and traveled through becoming famous together. So having a core group of people that have known you for a really long time.
My best friends in LA are still my friends Michael and Tobias. We were operators at 1-800-Dennis together. Wow. Before, you know, that's what I did. I did that and I did shows at improv theaters and to have that community that has known you that long is so important. And then I just, I like people and I like meeting people that love the office.
It makes me happy that they're still connecting to it like you and your daughter. Like, that's so cool. I love that. Are you guys ever over it? I don't. I mean, we were doing a podcast based on it, so I guess. No, no. I mean, yeah. I mean, and, you know, sometimes you get like I've seen like snarky comments on my Instagram or something where someone's like, get over it.
It was a long time ago. Like you still are talking about this thing. They're projecting their own failures on you. Well, I mean, my feeling is like, oh, I'm sorry, but I kind of did a super cool thing and I'm never getting tired of it. Like, it was awesome. Oh yeah, are you kidding me?
I'm milking it to the end. Yeah, absolutely. I think that's what smart people do. They find their thing and then they lean the fuck into it as hard as they can. So yeah, I will like yell save Bandit for you for your kid's birthday. Sure, why not?
I'm super proud of it. Yeah. You know, like, why would I get over it, you know? That's like, well, like Kate does the, she does the best cameos. She really does. Yeah. And she did one for my daughter. She actually knew it was from me.
We had met once. But the fact that she will say all the stuff and then gut her piano, play the theme song, I'm like, oh, it's so amazing. Yeah. It's exactly what a fan wants. And I like to give that to people. I mean, I didn't grow up in Hollywood.
I didn't grow up in this world. I grew up in St. Louis, Missouri, going to skate parks and, you know, being in the theater club. And oh, my gosh, to have, like, someone from that world that I dreamed about, like, say my name or shake my hand or take a picture with me, just how meaningful that would be. So cool. So I love to, like, my name or shake my hand or take a picture with me, just how meaningful that would be.
So I love to like give that out anytime I can. That's so amazing. Yeah. That's how I feel like if people come to my Instagram and like price of admission buddy, you're gonna get a lot of the office. How else did you find me? Yeah, exactly.
Oh, is it because I love hummingbirds? Is that why you're here? Did you call 1-800-DENIS at some point? Yeah, exactly. I will say that one of my most viral Instagram posts was, I brought it back from when I got to visit the set. I sat at the reception desk and put the phone in my ear. So a few years ago, I put just,
Birdhouse Skateboards, this is Tony. Oh, that's so good. I was gonna ask, yes, that's amazing. That went huge. Oh, that's great.. I was going to ask. Yes, that's amazing. That went huge. Oh, that's great. People are like, how the hell? What? Where did you? It was just like, because it's a time warp. Yeah.
Yeah. It totally is. Does the fame ever bother you? No, I, uh, only if it interferes with my family time. If I get stopped and it gets tricky and, you know, if I'm traveling with my kids or whatnot and I feel like they're getting slided. Uncomfortable or something. Yeah.
Yeah. Or if I feel like it's just taking away from that. But that's rare, honestly. And I mean, I still get to ride my skateboard for a living. I get paid to talk about skateboarding. Like it's just such a dream come true and I can't believe I still get to do it. So I'm super thankful and you know, I don't think I'm some polarizing figure. So people are generally very nice
and happy when they see me. And our video game series was a huge hit. So they like to talk about that and I played it. So I speak their language. Yeah, yeah. Are you good at your own video game? Yes, I'm good at playing with myself. That's what it is.
That was a very Michael Scott thing to say. That's what she said, it really was. Well, should we do our call she questions? Let's do it, let's do it. Okay, here they are. Number one, what was your very first entertainment job? I got to, I was on Captain Kangaroo. You were? How old were you?
I was skateboarding. I was like 11. Oh wow. Did all the ping pong balls drop? No, they shot, I didn't understand how TV worked at the time. So I thought Captain Kangaroo was coming to the skate park and we're going to do this whole thing. This crew came, shot me skating, and they made a little segment about it. Oh, okay.
So you didn't go to the set, but still. I didn't get to go to the set, but I mean, we sat and watched Captain Kangaroo one morning and I was on it. That's wild. That's pretty cool. Number two, do you speak any other languages or play a musical instrument?
I speak a little bit of French. I took a couple of years and then I spent about six weeks right after high school in France. So I understand it more than I speak it. Like we were there for the Olympics over the summer. I managed to navigate our family through some tricky security checkpoints, thanks to my French. So I feel like that was worth all the two years of it
in school. And I used to play violin. Do you still play violin? No, my music teacher, when I was 12, he wanted me to do these extracurricular school concerts and stuff on weekends. And that was when I would have to go compete. And I told him, no, I have to,
I'm going to compete in the skateboard event. And he said, well, you can't do both. What? You had to pick violin or skateboarding. According to him. That was a real sliding doors moment for you, I guess. It was, for sure. And I said, okay, well, this is way more fun for me.
And I didn't think I was choosing a future anyway. I was 12, you know what I mean? I know, exactly. I'm not gonna be a concert violinist or I'm not gonna be a pro skateboarder. I just love doing this. And so I chose, and I wish that I hadn't quit. I wish I hadn't really listened to him like that,
but he was the music teacher and he wasn't gonna let me keep being in his class. Yeah, that's not- Because I wasn't doing the other stuff. I tried to pick it up again and it wasn't like riding a bike. It wasn't. That's interesting. All right. What's a place you've been to that you absolutely loved? Firstly, Japan. I got to go there when I was 14 for a TV show called
basically Wonder Kids or Amazing Kids. And in my later years, Iceland. Oh, I'm going to Iceland this summer. Iceland's so cool. Oh, I can't wait. Yeah. All right, next one. What do you like to do on the weekends?
I like to try to be home and have our kids come home. Yeah. Because they are all pretty much gone. We only have one at home now, my daughter. We have five boys and they all are adults, but they do tend to migrate back home on the weekends. So I like to try to be home in case that happens. I love that. All right. Last one. Favorite midnight snack. That's tricky. Yeah, I don't like it. I like this kind of sweet popcorn.
Sweet popcorn? Like a kettle corn kind of thing? Yeah, but not too sweet. You know, the boom chicka boom. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That one's pretty good. A sweet and salty kind of thing. Either that or I go crackers, happy cow cheese and salami. You're speaking Angela's language. That's all I ever want. It's mirror and dear to her heart. That's a good one.
That's my favorite snack. A tangent to that question is, if you were standing in line for pretzel day, what's your order? Oh, wow. It would either be cinnamonous sugar or frosted. But I don't care about the sprinkles and I don't care about all the other accoutrements.
Okay. I'm cinnamon sugar. I'm cinnamon sugar. I'm cinnamon sugar. Yeah. Mm-hmm. Yeah, like a cinnamon toast vibe. Yes. Yep, yes.
That's it. It's pretty great. Am I gonna walk out the door and there's gonna be a pretzel cart? No, I wish we planned ahead. I wish, damn it! You guys need to figure a budget. Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Well, we would have asked that question at the beginning if that was the case. Oh, okay. Yeah, exactly. And here it is. Oh, man. Thank you so much for coming in. Yeah, thanks for having me. Yeah, this was so great.
Congratulations to you too. Thank you. Yeah, thanks. All right. Well, that happened, lady. Tony Hawk sat across from us for like an hour. And now we talked to him. I know. And we took pictures. We have the photos to prove it.
That's right. Thank you so much, Tony, for being on our podcast. And don't forget, everybody, Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 3 & 4 is out July 11th. You gotta grab it. Gotta grab it. And you know what? Tony also has a podcast. It's called Hawk versus Wolf. It's him and Jason Ellis, and it's a great podcast. So we'll put a link to that in our stories too. All right. Thank you so much everyone.
And we will see you next week. See you next week. ["Hawk vs. Wolf"] Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco.
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.